the president tonight had high praise
for his vice president tweeting out
quote
mike pence is doing great she is a gaff
machine
and by the way in case you're wondering
according to the stats
well senator harris had a lot more
speaking time at this debate
joining us now with reaction is donald
trump jr
um i i thought the vice president
it was like a surgical strike
effectively smoking out
the radical policies that joe biden and
kamala harris represent
which the medias have given them a pass
on up to this point
a hundred percent sean i felt like i
needed to dial 9-1-1 to report a murder
i mean he literally just
systematically destroyed joe biden's
failed record
kamala harris's disastrous record joe
biden's leniency and softness towards
china that allowed them to grow while
selling our american dream to them
for nothing i mean he really did a
perfect job
it was just awesome to watch uh and she
was just not prepared for it you could
see it in the facial expressions
uh in the attitude that she took in the
fact that she had to start resorting to
all sorts of lies and going back to the
usual lies that they've been pushing
uh for decades because you know of
course if you're the democrats the media
is not gonna
debunk uh things that are known to be
lies for you they'll let you get away
with it so she'll try to pull that over
the american people's eyes
but uh he didn't let her get away with
it and he did it with a smile on his
face it was an amazing performance
there was a moment let me play when when
vice president pence
blasted senator harris for undermining
the confidence in vaccines
now by the way your your dad the
president
uh he won't be the one that decides for
himself whether or not
a vaccine is safe that would be the
scientific community the scientific
researchers
um but there has been an
undermining going on and mike pence
called out
senator harris on this i think very
effectively let's roll that tape
the reality is that we're going to have
a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i just ask
you
stop playing politics with people's
lives
a powerful moment now your father
implemented there's a couple of things
where i thought the vice president set
the record straight
one was on the travel ban that through
the end of march joe biden was calling
hysterical xenophobia and fear mongering
that one decision as dr fauci has
pointed out in interviews with me
saved potentially hundreds of thousands
of lives maybe more
and that moment also uh joe
and kamala and the entire democratic
party were missing in action
all of those early months
uh 100 shown but that's the reality with
them i mean they're the party of science
when it behooves them right they're
they're all they always like to claim
that
except for when the facts don't line up
to what's going on when dr
fauci can get on the air and say that
was single-handedly the biggest decision
to save lives to stop the spread to stop
the exponential
growth of this virus that's why we
didn't see an
overwhelming of our hospitals that's why
no one went for want of a ventilator
you could combine that with donald trump
and mike pence's ability
to channel a public-private partnership
with so many of our great
corporations that took a businessman to
make that happen that's why you had
unprecedented success with ventilators
cutting the bureaucracy and the red tape
is what's allowing these medical
companies to get a vaccine through
in record time like it's never been done
before so you know meanwhile
they like to talk about the science of
you know climate change where
literally a 1.4 degree change in
difference in average temperature
over since i guess it's 1860
according to the science is responsible
for the disastrous
state of california where kamala harris
resides and is
the senator uh you know that's the kind
of nonsense that they're going to try to
push on the american people that 1.4
degrees is why california is burning
over 140 years
but the science from the cdc from the
experts in the medical community
that shouldn't count because it works
against us because they didn't do
anything for years
and they had no response when they had
their own pandemic which was fl
swine flu in 2009 which their own people
said
they handled disastrously and they were
just simply lucky
that it wasn't as deadly as this is let
me
let me go back to lies that were told in
the first debate
and told by kamala harris tonight that
we can easily fact check now i don't
assume
uh my esteemed colleagues that i call
the media mob will ever do this but she
got caught lying about
taxes because joe would repeal your
dad's tax cuts
which impact every american family but
this idea that neither one of them said
that they would ban fracking
they can say it but we still have
something called videotape
and they ought to be called out on it
because it's a flat out lie
and let's go to the videotape senator
harris you're
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the eye
and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee
that we will abolish fossil fuels
i am not banning frackie let me say that
again
i am not banning frackie no more no no
fracking
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in the biden administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated and no
more subsidies
for either one of those so first of all
i will repeat and the american people
know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a
fact will you commit to implementing a
federal
ban on fracking your first day in office
adding the united states
the list of countries who have banned
this devastating practice there's no
question i'm in favor of banning
fracking
so yeah you heard joe he'd eliminate
fracking no question
i'll eliminate fracking both of them lie
and they say oh we're not going to
eliminate fracking so what is it
there's a campaign there you can well i
can
yeah they obviously will i tweeted about
it during that because he said it on so
many occasions it's almost ridiculous
but that's the problem that's sort of
the
dilemma that we face joe biden said he
wasn't going to eliminate it in
pennsylvania where he knows that
fracking jobs
you know are a huge part of the economy
and the media will let him say that
there
he can then say exactly the opposite in
a more leftist crowd
to get the applause lines and they won't
say anything about the contradiction
in terms that's the problem that's what
we face he's allowed to lie
he can lie to the american people just
like kamala harris can lie to the people
about the taxes
just like she can lie about the
charlottesville nonsense to give one
line and a quote when it's very clear if
you read the full sentence
everything that he's talking about but
they continue to run with it
they continue to get away with it the
media continues to pretend that it's
even remotely truthful
uh and that's the nature of the game and
that's why it's so important for us to
be able to correct these things
on the record in real time when we come
back
i'm going to show the full
charlottesville tape i'll show all the
times that your dad has condemned
white nationalism and white supremacy
and david duke
and all of these groups and what he said
in charlottesville because that too is a
lie told tonight
that's all coming up don jr thank you